I really loved Fitness macro counting
different ways to exercise different
programming stuff and I was obsessed
with it so much so that the people that
I worked with were like dude if you
don't start a gym I'll pay for the gym
so that you stop talking about this
stuff there are three paths that every
entrepreneur eventually has to take you
have the path of the pure artist The
Craft of the pure entrepreneur and then
a hybrid path so the path of the artist
is the person who loves doing the thing
now your art form might be Plumbing your
art form might be carpentry coding
software making media and making wallets
you have something that you enjoy doing
and you do it well the second path on
the extreme is that you love business
business is your art form and it doesn't
really matter what business you're in I
love working with different portfolio
companies whether it's solar sales
mortgage sales physical products
software service businesses brick and
mortar chains like we have all of those
in our portfolio and I love growing them
all and that's because the art for me is
the actual business itself the third
path is a hybrid path and each of these
paths can go all the way to the max
limit here so an example is Tobias Luca
who is the founder of Shopify and so he
loves building Shopify pages and he
loves the coding and the product and so
what he did was he found somebody else
and have them build the business around
him while he stayed focused on the main
thing that he loved the most the key
here is that there is no right path it's
more about the path that works best for
you during the season you're in because
guess what you can also change paths
later if you start in the artist path
you might transition to the hybrid path
or you might start on the honest path
and go all the way to the entrepreneur
path when I started I really loved
Fitness I was obsessed with Fitness I
had spent years I had competed in
Fitness and so all I read all day
besides a little bit of personal
development was like macro counting
different ways to exercise different
programming stuff like exercise for ways
to layer workouts program all that kind
of stuff and I was obsessed with it so
much so that the people that I worked
with were like dude if you don't start a
gym I'll pay for the gym so that you
stop talking about this as soon as I
actually started a gym I realized I
enjoyed business even more than I
enjoyed Fitness I started as an artist
of fitness and I became an entrepreneur
but let me play out all three paths to
their natural extremes The Artist At Its
extreme is somebody who continues to not
scale an Enterprise around them and
continues to do the thing at
extraordinarily high levels and so this
ultimately goes from a commoditized
price point to a premium price point to
a luxury price point all right so
Commodities price point is like if
you're a plumber you do the same
Plumbing work everyone else does right
now if you start doing it really well
Word of Mouth starts to build and you
can start raising your prices because
you are now a premium provider you do
better work you do it faster people come
to you because they trust your work
right now at the highest level it
becomes luxury you become so advanced in
plumbing you can do it for a massive
building or you can do it for luxury
homes and you make it look more neat and
awesome and cool and whatever what
happens is demand continues to increase
for your services or your product and so
rather than increase the number of units
you sell you just increase the price you
still make significantly more money and
a lot more profit in that business model
but it still keeps you doing the core
thing which is that you like Plumbing
you like making wallets you like being a
carpenter whatever you can have
incredible artists who sell their
paintings for millions of dollars a
piece and they don't have a massive
organization around their main thing
that they focus on every day is the art
now there's obviously elements of
Entrepreneurship there but because they
make money the hybrid version developer
who built the little website because he
wanted to make some sort of physical
products business that he didn't like
the tools that are out there and he
started making it but then other people
because the product was so good started
asking for it now he could have just
continued to raise the price of the
thing but at a certain point especially
with software it made more sense to make
himself Chief product officer rather
than CEO and then hired a CEO and hired
the executive team to build everything
else around him because he's a big
shareholder he has a lot of sway but on
the actual chart itself he might be over
here not necessarily at the top because
he doesn't want that life you still do
your art every day but then you find the
people now that does require skill
because you need to have the perspective
from which to make a judgment on who is
good enough to be able to lead your
company now that's where having outside
advisors and things like that to help
you find those people who you do trust
who already have that skill who don't
have a vested interest in your business
so they can give you the cleanest purest
advice the highest level of advice is
someone who has been there done that
themselves and taken other people just
like me to where I'm trying to go
multiple times a level below that is
someone who has taken multiple people
like me where I'm trying to go they
haven't done it themselves the level
below that is someone who's only done it
themselves and helps no one else the
level below that is someone who saw
someone go all the way themselves or saw
multiple other people go there
themselves below that is only seeing one
person and below that is your mama uncle
and your neighbor telling you their two
cents about how you should do business
when they've never run a business and
have no no right to have an opinion you
can leverage their experience to find
the right people to fit inside of your
business to build the business around
you the third path is that of the
entrepreneur that's the person whose art
form is the businesses and so rather
than thinking about making wallets and
making more wallets the business itself
is the painting and so they will have
multiple paintings in their career as
they develop as an artist so too does
their expression of their art and so the
types of businesses they build get
bigger more complex more or need or
simpler right it just depends on what
type of entrepreneur they are I'll tell
you right now the amount of businesses
that I've started I started a non-profit
online training business I switched to a
for-profit training business and then I
switched to a brick and mortar gym then
I had a chain of gyms then I had a gym
turnaround business I had a car tractor
agency I had a dental agency I had a
licensing business I've had an
e-commerce business that sold physical
products had a software business
software to service B2B and now I have
private Equity Firm and I'm 33. as you
develop as an entrepreneur your art will
change and it will be continually a
changing expression of who you are and
it will evolve so the biggest question
is which of the three are you if you
love the actual doing of the business
the thing you do the product or service
you deliver that is your art then I
would say start with the path of the
artist and if you're good because if you
really do love it you should be able to
beat other people who don't love it and
so you should naturally through Word of
Mouth be able to get more demand than
you have supply of time at that point
you'll have to start making the decision
am I going to go hybrid are I going to
go all the way entrepreneur if you're
starting out right now and you're
watching these videos and you just love
entrepreneurship in general and you
don't really care what you sell you just
want to make money then you probably are
more the entrepreneur path you just want
to hustle you want to figure out needs
in the marketplace figure out stuff that
people are buying connect the two dots
build the organization around it put an
operator in charge and then let it run
and make cash flow that's the
entrepreneur path the middle path the
hybrid path is usually someone who
starts as an artist and then becomes
that because they still want to build
build the beginner prize but they don't
want to sacrifice the thing they love
the most which is actually building the
product this little product thing as a
side note could also be marketing it
could also be Finance if you like a
certain component of the business you
can own that component of the business
and have someone build it around you you
could just be the guy who loves
fundraising and you just love raising
funds and that's how you build your
business and you get everybody else
around you to run it you will still
leave your thumbprint on different
aspects and be more heavily involved in
different departments the ones that you
love the most but at this point you do
it by choice rather than do it by
obligation do I love the thing or do I
love the business of doing the thing and
then walking that path down and the best
news is you can always change your mind
later the most valuable skill that you
can have in order is product first then
marketing then sales and so right now if
you know how to sell it's because you
don't know how to Market you know how to
build products if you know how to market
then you can sell lots of stuff but
you're only going to sell it once
because the product's usually not that
good if you know how to sell product
you'll get more promotion from your
customers than anything else and that is
ultimately what scales the Enterprise
marketing can scale anything to a point
and then what happens is the marginal
cost of getting the next customer
continues to get oh up and up and if you
don't get Word of Mouth referrals from
customers who use your product then
eventually it becomes untenable and your
company will Plateau and so the key to
building a very very big thing that
lasts for a very long time is have an
exceptional product and I get that
you're like sure but how do I make money
and you know what if you just sell
you can make money if you Market
well you can make even more money and
what happens for most entrepreneurs is
they actually go in that direction they
just learn how to sell because
that's the easiest skill to learn you
can learn it in a couple weeks learn how
to Market takes a little longer you
learn how to write copy it's really just
translating the persuasion of sales into
different types of media and selling to
many people at once and so the highest
leverage thing you can do is make an
exceptional product that other people
want to promote for you my first real
big experience with this was the book so
100 million dollar offers is a book it's
99 Cents you get on Amazon like right
now it sells 25 000 copies a month with
no paid ads the reason for that and a
lot of people who knew me from high
school or new me from college are like
dude it's so crazy some guy I know from
work is like dude you got to read this
book and it was your book you have more
people who send you business than people
who leave just based on how good your
product is that continues to compound to
the end of time